hi i'm presenting randomness and
fairness
in two-sided matching with limited
interviews my name is heather bayaki i'm
a postdoc at ttic
and this is a joint work with eva tardis
in this paper we study matching markets
where both sides of the matching have
limitations
on one side we have applicants who
although find a lot of the job positions
on the other side desirable
can only apply to a limited number of
them this could be because the system
has imposed this limit
or since the applications are time
consuming and costly they can only apply
to a limited number
and on the other side we have the job
positions that need to
run an interview process before hiring
applicants
and again since the interview process is
time consuming and costly
they can only interview a limited number
of their applicants
our goal in this paper is to study the
effect of these limitations
and the matching and more particularly
the size of the matching
traditionally the matching algorithms
did not consider these kinds of
limitations into account for example the
deferred acceptance algorithm by gail
and shapley
that finds a stable matching assumes
that participants can
consider as many options as they want
in the more recent years there have been
more work on
matching with limitations and here
there's a subset of them but as you see
there have been very few
works on where there's limitation on
both sides of the matching
and they either consider different
settings or different objectives
okay let me define our model more
formally
we have n applicants and n positions
we show applicants by circles and the
positions by squares
we focus on the case where the
preferences
of each participant over the other side
comes
independently and uniformly at random
which kind of means that
each position or each applicant is
equally popular this assumption makes
our analysis tractable
and also we see interesting facts even
in the simple case
we run a three-stage matching mechanism
in the first stage
each applicant applies to k positions in
this picture k equals two
and right next to each position we see
the applications that they have received
in the second stage the positions accept
k
prime of their applications for
interviews and make interview offers
for to them and reject the rest
here k prime is also equal to 2 so
this position accepts the orange and
blue
applications but rejects the green
application
then we run the interview process
and each participant refines their
preferences and after that
we run the applicant proposing deferred
acceptance algorithm
we're going to assume that at each stage
the participants choose their favorite
options
this makes sense because of the
independent and uniform preferences
this means that in the first stage
each applicant is applying to their k
favorite positions
and the positions are accepting their
key prime favorite applications and
reject the rest
and this is a truthful based nash
equilibrium in this setting
finally we consider the large market
setting
which means which is a standard
assumption in matching papers
it means that we keep k and k prime
constant while we study the case where n
approaches infinity and the large market
setting
makes sense because if we had a small
market
limitation limitations didn't really
make sense
the problem that we're going to study
from here on is
finding the expected size of the
matching or the fraction of matched
participants
as a function of k and k prime the limit
on the number of applications and the
limit on the number of interviews
okay now let's focus on the case where
we have a limit of 1
on the number of interviews
our first observation in this case is
that
the matching mechanism becomes much
simpler so
after the applicants apply to the
positions and the positions accept
only one application we don't
actually need to run the deferred
acceptance algorithm
basically each applicant that receives
an interview offer
is going to be matched finally i should
mention that in this
case we don't really have the interview
process
but we're still calling
the acceptance of applications an
interview offer just to be consistent
throughout the talk
now let's solve the easy case where both
the limit on the number of applications
and on the number of interviews is one
each applicant is applying to one
position
so in total we're going to have n
applications and remember from our model
that
all the preferences are independent so
we have n
independent applications sent uniformly
and independently to the positions
so it's easy to find the probability
that the position receives an
application it's actually a simple
wall symptoms analysis and when
n goes to infinity this approaches 1
minus 1 over e
in this case since each applicant has
only one application
they are going to receive at most one
interview offer
so they're going to accept it anyway and
the number of
positions that received an application
is going to be
the same as the number of applicants
that are matched
okay now let's get back to the
more general case of arbitrary number of
applications
in the single interview offer
it took us some time to realize that
this also has a very simple
solution and it's going to fit on one
slide
our first insight is that when n
approaches infinity we may assume that
the applications are
independent so technically with a finite
n different applications of a single
applicant are not independent they are
going to k distinct positions but as
n goes to infinity even if we draw a
fresh sample from the independent
from the uniform distribution the
probability that
this is going to be the same position as
the k minus one other application tends
to zero
so in the limit we may assume that all
applications of a single applicant are
independent
previously we knew that the applications
of different applicants
are also independent so basically we
have
n times k applications that are sent
independently and uniformly at random to
the positions
as a side note this is kind of like a
new variation of the balls in balance
problem
so the balls here are the applicants
and each we can think that there are
multiple copies of each ball
and these are all sent independently and
uniformly
to the bins and the bins have capacity
of one
and for example the problem that you're
studying here is the number of
distinct balls that fit into the bins
okay back to our problem so with
n times k and applications sent
independently to the positions
we can find the probability of an
application being accepted
so by definition it's going to be the
total number of accepted applications
over the total number of applications
okay
and there is a one-to-one correspondence
between the accepted applications
and the positions that have received any
application because each position that
receives
any application is going to exactly
accept one application
all right and
we can find the number or the expected
number of positions with applications
pretty easily similar to our analysis on
the last slide
so with nk applications this is going to
be the probability that
um a position receives any application
so this times
n is the number of positions with
applications
and the total number of applications is
n times k
all right so now from
a random applicant's point of view each
of their applications
have the same probability p of being
accepted
therefore the probability that an
applicant
receives any interview offer is going to
be
1 minus 1 minus p to the k and we are
substituting
p from here so we get this number and
from two slides ago we know that
the size of the matching in this case is
the number of applicants that
have any accepted applications
all right so let's see
what is what this function looks like as
a function of k
all right okay so we have this diagram
here the x-axis is k the number of
applications
and the y-axis is the size of the
matching or the fraction of matched
agents
as you see as we increase the number of
applications
first the size of the matching is going
to increase
and then it's going to decrease so this
is the first interesting fact that we
see
the size of the matching is not
monotone in the number of the
applications
okay so at one we have the around 63
percent that we saw
on the last slide 1 minus 1 over e and
you may find it interesting that
this curve converges to 1 minus 1 over e
at the end
which is equal which is equal to the
value of a single application
okay so
based on the formula we know that the
shape looks like this but
what is the main reason that it's not
monetary
we find out that having more
applications have both
a positive and negative effect the
positive effect is that with more
applications
the number of positions that have
received any application increases
so with only one application only 63
of the positions have received some
application but as we increase this
number
you see that it grows up pretty fast
the negative effect is that since the
applicants are applying to
multiple places the probability of
an accepted application belonging to
somebody who has
already other accepted application goes
high
so we will have a bunch of people who
have received multiple applications
while the rest have received zero so we
see that
after we have three applications the
negative effect takes over
and we will have a decreasing size of
matching
okay so the next question that we want
to study is that
is there any hope of getting a larger
size matching
if we have a different distribution of
the number of applications
or basically what if what happens if the
applicants can apply to different number
of additions
they don't have to all apply to k
positions
okay so this lemma here tells us that
if some applicant applies to x positions
and another applicant applies to y
positions
while the difference between these
numbers is at least two
we can redistribute these applications
and
make their number of applications closer
to each other and increase the size of
the matching
and the proof is actually
straightforward all right
so it has a simple corollary
that says that given any average number
of applications
x the size of the matching is maximized
if the applicants either apply to x
number of positions or ceiling x number
of positions
basically applying to the same number of
positions or two consecutive numbers
is the best way of distributing the
applications
okay so let's see what is the size of
the matching in this case
all right so we have x as the average
number of applications
and we're going to have this fraction of
people applying to
florex applications and this fraction
applying to
ceiling x application and the
probability of
the applicants being matched is similar
to the
solution from the previous slides
and we can also find a
p similar to before all right
now let's see the shape of this figure
okay so again on the x-axis we have the
average number of applications and the
y-axis
is the size of the matching or fraction
of matched agents
and for example at 2.5 half of the
applicants are applying to two positions
while the second half are applying to
three positions okay
so here we see our second interesting
fact
the u-shaped between the two integers
so what is basically happening
is that if you start from so first of
all
it means that having all the applicants
applied to three positions is the best
even if you're allowed to pick other
distributions of applications
so three applications is still optimal
and
when we have a limited number of
interviews we need to also limit the
number of applications
to have a good size of matching and
secondly
the maximum magic is achieved with a
fair system of
allocating the applicants for example
if you're here at um three applications
if we allow a group of people if we
favor a group of people and let them
apply to
one more position the size of the
matching decreases
also if we discriminate against a group
of people
and um let them apply to one less
position
the state of dimension decreases and the
local maxima of this
figure are going to be the integer
values
we call this scallop shaped figure so
basically
when people apply to the same number of
positions
we get the maximum size matchings
okay so far we understand completely
what happens with a single interview
case now let's move on to multiple
interviews
so we're when we are in the multiple
interview case for example when the
positions accept two of their
applications
we really need to actually run the
different acceptance algorithm
so the solution for this case is going
to be much more technical although the
solutions is so clean but i won't get to
talk about that in the talk
and please check out the paper if you're
curious about the analysis
but at the end of the day we managed to
find the expected size of the matching
even
with the more complicated deferred
acceptance algorithm
and we come up with the size of the
matching
all right so here the x-axis is again
the average number of applications
the y-axis is the size of the matching
or the fraction of mesh participants
uh we see the curve that we saw
previously for
k equals one here and here we have the
curve
for k prime equals one here we have the
care for k prime equals two
three and so on
so as you see still our two weird
facts uh the non-monotonicity in the
number of
applications and also the u shape
between the two
um consecutive integers happens here but
to a lesser degree
before we finish i want to emphasize
that
these weird behaviors are a consequence
of limiting
the number of interviews if we don't
have any limit on the number of
interviews
the matching size is going to be
monotonically increasing
and actually it's not so on the right
hand side you see
the size of the matching when we have no
limits on the number of interviews and
the x-axis is the average number of
applications
and it's actually uh not hard to prove
this theoretically basically we're
running the deferred acceptance
algorithm
and with more applications it's like
we're
appending the lists so
with these longer lists with this longer
preference list
we definitely come up with a larger size
matchings
okay let me conclude
our main technical contributions are one
computing
the expected size of the matching as a
result of the deferred acceptance
algorithm
as a function of the limit on the number
of applications and interviews
and two we find the optimal way of
distributing
distributing the applications
when given a fixed average number of
applications
uh our work suggests two policy
recommendations
first is that if there is a limited
ability in granting interviews
we need to limit the number of
applications and sometimes we need to
severely limit the number of
applications that the applicants can
send
in order to achieve a larger size
matching
and the second is that the optimal
matching size is achieved by a fair
system where
all the applicants apply to the same
number of positions
i would like to mention two open
problems the first one is
relaxing that the preferences come from
uniform distributions
maybe that's the main step to make the
model more realistic
so fortunately there have been some work
on correlated distributions
but the usual assumption
is that the preferences of the
applicants
or the preferences of the positions are
almost identical
so our work is kind of the other extreme
case where the preferences are
completely random but it would be nice
to have some results um
in the between and the second open
problem
is to study other matching mechanisms
other than
the deferred acceptance algorithm um so
we still have the same
first stage but we're changing the
matching mechanism and to compare these
different mechanisms
that's all thank you so much for
watching